I think within the last year or so for
max Holloway or like when max hallways
face goes up on the screen people go
nuts as they know he throws down yeah I
think it was a word take a fight I
really think that Ortega if I made him a
superstar I really did although one's
definitely helped them sure the back to
back although ass weapons in the
Northland Ortega the thing that was
different those Ortega had a big
following Ortega was the young beautiful
lion lion with fantastic jiu-jitsu
handsome guy cool smooth talker looks
like a champion yeah fucking everybody
up so he had a lot of fans coming in
there and they went to war they went to
war and Max came out on top and I think
max a lot of those PB cuz they were so
cool with each other during before and
after people loved it - max is the he
loses better than anyone on the fucking
planet
what losses or wins he just goes hey I'm
just gonna get better he doesn't lose a
lot he doesn't know I mean he lost it
Connor he lost confidence is very clever
you know but I twenty years old but I
also think max is it because we've
always said I think both of us have been
agreement where if a guy is cutting a
ton of weight and killing himself go to
the next weight class I've always said
that whether it was Darren till whether
you know Chris Weidman Luke Rockhold
John Jones like Duke go up a weight
class dominate and then this is kind of
the first time we've seen a guy where
it's like mmm it's not that easy because
max Holloway went up but you could see
the power wasn't there like he might
have eaten he did he landed more than
Dustin Poirier but when Dustin hit
landed it thought you could see that it
fucking counted Dustin is big dude he's
big Mary he's from a 45-ton used to
fight a 45 and really struggled there
but at 55 he's found a spot and you look
at him he almost looks like a
welterweight I mean he's big he looks
like tyron woodley size and he cuts a
shitload of weight and max Holloway and
that fight just looked like they didn't
look like the same no just poori like
fucking meaty well and you gotta give
credit to Poirier too because if you
look at the two of them like after the
fight there was a big difference in the
amount of damage the Portland a big
difference he was hitting him with big
shots and it wasn't just big shots it
was shots period he was hitting him with
really clean well time
with great head movement great movement
that knee dude everything split open his
head yeah everything he did everything
great I mean he really that was a
coming-out party for Dustin Poirier in a
lot of ways for the common fan well yeah
well the people that knew him from the
gay gee fight noon from the Eddie
Alvarez fight they knew that man he beat
these two really good guys but max
Holloway might be one of the best
pound-for-pound fighters in the world
and I think is I think's tonight always
the greatest 145 of all time yes I think
he's a damn good 55 er but but 55 could
be tough for max well this is a great
example of what we've always said about
the differences between the size of
people and this isn't it's it's first of
all I mean all credit to Dustin Poirier
cuz he put on a phenomenal performance
he got you know he got tested in that
fight he came through he even talked
about in the post fight interview that
he got hurt in the third round he came
through and just super impressive think
about his liking tennis Anthony Pettis
world champion ehe world champion Eddie
Alvarez world champion max Holly world
champ edits one though wasn't that an
injury I feel like Pettis got injured
they stopped the fight I did break his
hand is that what happened no I feel
like the Pettis one was an injury yet
the issues with Eddie Alvarez right
which was a no contest
yeah I think well there was one fight
where Dustin Poirier and no yeah I think
it I think that was it there was
remember Pettis where peds broke his
hand Duke Rufus stopped the fight
remember that Tony Ferguson was it Tony
for this Tony Ferguson you're right
right but I think that's a great Brown
maybe was an injury I was a rib member
oh that's right that's right
Dustin got on top of him and hurt his
wrist right but still look at place wins
man yeah well that's a weird one too
right it's cuz like what was that rib
injury from a Poirier body shot yeah
what was that from or is it from the
takedown like what was it something
happened yeah I don't remember that's
right but you were like a TKO
yeah you look at poor Hayes yeah his
list man the guy said who's fighting
he's lost too it's so impressive yeah
and poor is the guy same thing with when
Michael Bisping won I always root for
those guys those guys who've been around
forever and they fight the best of the
best they might lose one or
to here but they've been around for so
long you just hope there's a title at
the end of their career
yeah you just hope and it sometimes
doesn't look like it's gonna happen then
when it does happen I just I'm just so
happy for this good guy too
Dustin Poirier great guy he's a great
guy he's smart he's ambitious Neil
Vaughn's favorite fighter works hard the
whole heiresses that scene those two
guys together that was hilarious caught
on the rainbow with the same whole
school
how about Theo was yelling instructions
I'm gonna I see my king of sting I'm
gonna roast the shit out of him did you
yell take him down what what is
happening right now why does this happen
yeah shouting in surely the UFC provides
me with headphones I was hoping you were
to turn around like dude what are you
doing
I love the oh he's the best yeah such a
character unique kid he was so happy he
was so happy I mean him bad well I just
bet because I'll see him and you thought
that did you think I'd be a great fight
I thought max at 55 if everything was
going to carry with him I thought max
would probably get it done by it was
gonna be a good fight I was just betting
feel because Theo his boys with doesn't
run from the same area so it's just a
friendly bet I would never bet against
us emporia look at these fools we're
gonna fight before he texts me halfway
through goes dude I can't believe you
did this shit I know maybe a little
respect now around King the sting all
right
you little fucking respect bro yeah he
was looking at it as a complete outsider
there's no idea I told him I said super
intense man your scene for the best
fighters on planet Earth